[Music]
let's go out to green bay wisconsin and
talk to lynn hey lynn what's going on
hey um
i'm calling because i needed some
thoughts and ideas um i am going to be
locked in a pretty intense custody
battle that i didn't see coming
um what happened
i'm sorry
what happened
uh we went well i had my baby and
um he met her once
um for a couple of hours and then just
kind of disappeared and i didn't really
push things
um
back it back up so this is the father of
this baby we're all married
no we were not we were supposed to be
but i found out about a bunch of
infidelity and that was the end of it so
you had your baby and then the father of
that baby
saw her for just a few minutes and then
he took off and disappeared
for for a couple of hours the week that
she was born he um he met with her
but he didn't see her after that he did
text for a while asking general
questions but
after a while he would um text
how is she doing and i would respond
she's good do you want to see her this
weekend and then he wouldn't respond and
we kind of rinsed and repeated that for
i want to say about four or five times
and then
um late october early november he just
stopped all contact um and i didn't
reach out because i didn't want to chase
him down and i had other things to worry
about sure you have a human being you're
keeping alive that's right
um
well uh
last one or the wednesday before last i
got served papers for a court hearing
and i work
i get my mail in the evening and i work
the weekends and so i wasn't able to
look into an attorney or really review
the paper so i had made an attempt to
call him to see what he would want for
the proposed parenting plan
and he didn't answer so when we went
into the well the court was over the
phone
um so
when i went there i had dropped off the
papers about 10 minutes before the
hearing because i was trying to get
everything to the court
on time
and i didn't have an attorney and um at
that point my
ex had said that he wanted full
placement and full custody under
allegations that i was horrifically
abusive and he feared for the life of
his child oh my gosh
i'm so sorry um
which put us in the position of having
to skip past mediation and go straight
to guardian medlita
which is where the court assigns an
attorney to the kind of to the child
um
and so
um
take a second this is hard this is hard
um this is your baby how old is this
girl
she's 10 months 10 months wow
i'm so sorry and there's there's a
shock element to this right this is uh
something that you didn't see coming
right
no i i didn't um
i thought because i had been amicable
and i had
um offered for him to see her on
weekends that he would take me up on
that if he wanted um
and i've had people in my personal life
ask you know why why would he do this
what did he want i i the only answer
i've been able to give him is to um
to punish me because i i didn't
need him and i didn't call back to him
or
anything
um i'm going to give you a piece of
wisdom moving forward okay
there's a whole psychology about this
but i'll keep it real simple
stay out of his head
okay
why he's doing what he's doing is his
problem not yours
your energy and your focus is on
protecting this baby
and
making sure that um
things stay the way they are and by the
way while we're at it we need some child
support too
okay
why he's doing this
it doesn't matter yeah yeah what
this does he have an attorney
uh he does and i didn't know that until
um
until the day that i had called and
asked the court if there had been any
movement on the case
and that's when they let me know
but they said that he hadn't responded
to the paternity test and so they were
still awaiting papers before they could
put anything in motion
i mean at some point he's gonna have to
answer for the unpaid child support of
11 months and he's going to have to
answer for the text messages that you
have in writing
about how you reached out and tried to
offer support and he would never respond
he'll have to respond to the
phone records where you call him and he
doesn't answer
right so i don't know what his
attorney's trying to do but this isn't a
very winnable case
um
i don't have the copy of the text
messages because my my phone ended up
with an error on june 3rd and everything
was deleted that i couldn't get to my
computer and the only thing i could get
to my computer was when i would plug it
in it would automatically ask if i
wanted to download any
pictures or videos
okay let's do this because i don't want
to get into legal stuff like this you
need to talk to your an attorney about
that and um the phone the phone company
should have the records that you need
all that to say is this um
i want you to get online and google
family um
court programs in your area
okay
okay
and there will be low-income resources
for people who need attorneys for for
family matters
okay okay if if they are unable to serve
you i want you to call a local the
nearest law school that you have and ask
for referral services either through
one of their in-house programs or one of
the externship programs or they will
have a list of people who take on cases
like this either pro bono or on a
sliding scale
because there's a group of attorneys and
in another state i'm friends with some
of them who love
taking these kind of cases
because it's right
and it's the right thing to do okay but
we're looking for family court programs
or family law service programs
and even if you call a family lawyer in
town and say hey i don't have any money
this got sprung on me all of a sudden
this guy's coming out of the woodwork
after a year trying to claim things that
just bananas they may not be able to
take your services but they'll have some
refer
some referrals for you to call
for somebody to walk alongside you um in
a way that you can afford it or will be
a free referral service
i'm so so sorry that you're going
through this and this has come out of
the left field on you
um
again stay at his head
stay out of all the drama don't be a
part of the drama be a part of getting
the legal counsel that you need and
somebody to protect you and take care of
you and that baby through this process
so we can retain custody and move on
with our lives and by the way that dude
needs to pay yours worth of child
support and make a plan moving forward
because there's 17 more years in that
baby's life
so so sorry that you're dealing with
this what a heartbreak what a heartbreak